je suis lucide bertone j'ai eu l'idée de
créer incroyable couvert comestibles
notre mission débarrasser la planète des
couverts en plastique jetables et sauver
le monde
une bouchée à la fois je dois avouer que
je suis vraiment déçu d'accord oui je
vais le refaire
écoute la beyoncé y est en toi mon ami
ok écoutez moi bien les incroyables
mangeable comestibles incroyable comme
excuse chacun son point de vue mais
c'est vous qui payez ces prêts à relever
le grand défi de l'esprit d'équipé
non si on réussit à relever le défi du
parcours haut niveau avec les galeries
souterraines les plus profondes du
nouveau mexique
on sera prêts à relever les défis de
l'environnement économique d'aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que ça va j'ai fait une formation
rcp way to dressé pour renforcer notre
esprit d'équipé
c'est une opportunité c'est comme si
nous faisions notre propre et ce
quelqu'un
qu'est-ce qui peut être pire que cette
situation imagine cette situation mais
en plus tu es mort ça fait dix jours que
débloquer en scavo la plus longue durée
qu'un être humain et tony sans avoir ni
manger dans environ une semaine et dans
cette grotte il nous manque les deux
alors il ya une source alimentaire qu'on
n'a pas en france étudier sérieux je
crois que c'est une décision que nous
devrions prendre ensemble et il faut
penser collectif et non individuel
mon estomac il est plutôt individuelle
dans sa façon de penser et à minima et
neymar winstein moi je suis là winch
team de personnes règle numéro 1 suivez
les instructions à la seconde où je les
donne je suis déçu par chacun d'entre
vous si jamais on vient manger brandon
je me demande comment on s'y prendra qui
est suivi un cours de préparation de sa
chimie au japon pays avait le découpage
de la chaurienne on a travaillé sur le
saut
[Musique]